vingt articles pour une addition de
quelques 20 milliards d'euros qui
devrait permettre aux français et puis
menez modeste peut faire le plein de
payer le loyer de remplir le sac de
courses bref de faire face à l'inflation
d'examen du texte a commencé cet après
midi en séance publique à l'assemblée
nationale gros plan sur cette
indispensable loi fourre tout avec samia
de chiens
c'est le premier texte d'envergure du
quinquennat un projet de loi à 20
milliards d'euros pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux français
confronté à une inflation galopante
le gouvernement prévoit de prolonger le
bouclier tarifaires sur les prix du gaz
et de l'électricité jusqu'à la fin de
l'année d'accorder un chèque
alimentaires de 100 euros + 50 euros par
enfant à 8 millions de ménages
l'exécutif veut aussi progressivement
remplacer la remise de carburant de 18
centimes par une indemnité carburant
pour les travailleurs versée sous
conditions de ressources par une simple
déclaration sur un site dédié ils
pourront toucher un chèque de 100 à 300
euros en tenant compte d'un bonus en
fonction du fait d'être un très gros
rouleurs ou pas très drôle très drôle
ans et plus 30 kilomètres pour aller
travailler et plus de 12000 km par an le
pack pouvoir d'achat prévoit aussi une
revalorisation de 3 5% du point d'indicé
des fonctionnaires et des aides au
logement les retraites et minimas
sociaux augmenteront de 4 % des mesures
insuffisantes pour l'opposition de
gauche qui réclamait une augmentation
des salaires et un smic à 1500 euros
vous avez déjà vu du point d'indicé +3
5% de fonction réelle 3 5% +3 25%
prestations sociales minima social + 4 %
retraite + 4 % de combien va être
l'inflation d'ici la fin de l'année 5
18% pour l'instant % d'ici la fin de
l'année donc en fait on acte quelque
chose qui en fait une baisse de pouvoir
d'achat pour les gens ont vu de
l'augmentation des prix absolument
vertige et nommer son autre mesure
critiquée par l'anus le triplement de la
prime macron ce coup de pouce
défiscaliser que les patrons peuvent
verser à leurs employés dont le plafond
passe à 3000 euros le texte ne fait pas
non plus l'unanimité à droite et au
rassemblement national en tout plus de
mille amendements ont été déposés
cette fois pouvoir d'achat on en parle
ce soir
avec mes invités bonsoir crise elle
rappelait sage est directrice adjointe
de bva opinion j'accueille également
bruno cautrès politologue chercheur au
cnrs au cevipof
eric delannoy vous êtes économiste sont
amateurs du cabinet de conseil tenzing
et puis guillaume daret journaliste en
génétique bienvenue guillaume kim
accueillera tout au long de l'émission
et que nous retrouverons aussi mercredi
c'est certes je ne m'abuse alors ce
paquet pouvoir d'achat gel et à l'heure
c'est un texte piège est ce que c'est un
texte piège d'abord parce qu'il suscite
beaucoup d'attentes chez les français
oui tout à fait c'est un texte
fondamental pourquoi parce qu'ils
touchent finalement la préoccupation
numéro un des français le pouvoir
d'achat on a vu cette préoccupation
fortement augmenté durant toute la
campagne présidentielle législatives
avant le crime et même elle est restée
très haute alors avec la santé aussi un
qui reste un sujet phare pour les
français mais voilà ils sont inquiets et
nous quand on les interroge dans nos
enquêtes même spontanément ils nous
disent quand on leur dit c'est quoi
votre état d'esprit ils nous disent ben
moi je suis inquiet et notamment je suis
inquiet par la vie chère c'est un thème
qui va même énergie spontanément donc on
va à quel point il les touche sa touche
leur quotidien et donc forcément ma un
texte qui en parlent ils vont le scruter
avec attention et puis c'était un thème
très politisé vous l'avais dit à la fois
pendant la campagne présidentielle
pendant la campagne des législatives
et puis c'est un texte piège parce qu'il
intervient aussi pas n'importe quel
moment une semaine seulement après
l'échec du projet de loi sanitaire on le
rappelle il ya une semaine la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale la
du ps le rassemblement national et une
partie une large part très large partie
de vos pairs ont mis en minorité le
gouvernement sur sur le texte sanitaire
est ce que la majorité joue gros la
majorité relative présidentielle jour où
d'un point de vue politique et
symbolique monaco 13 oui parce qu'il
s'agit d'une série de tests pour cette
fameuse nouvelle méthode qui est de
gouverner par concertation de remettre
le parlement au centre est bien de la
fabrique des décisions publiques donc
effectivement ça joue très très gros
parce que emmanuel macron avoue ne me
théorisé ce qui était au fond ce qui
n'est pas un choix de sa base se situe à
c'est une contrainte il nous l'a
présenté l'autre jour un petit peu comme
si ça venait du fin fond de son logiciel
politique et qu'il avait toujours au
fond souhaiter ça mélange
quand même un test voilà très important
sur 7 sur cette méthode est par ailleurs
il ya une autre dimension qui se joue au
delà de des premiers on va dire des
premiers crash test de cette méthode
c'est où va le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron est ce qu'à travers
ces premières discussions s 4 à ses
premiers textes de loi on commence à
voir s'affirmer quelque part est bien là
la direction principale de politique
publique que emmanuel macron veut
incarner sur la méthode ou sur le fond
sur les deux sur la méthode évidemment
mais sur le fond sur le fond là la
concerne est un protecteur c'est ça la
confusion est toujours un petit peu
présente beaucoup s'interrogent quelle
est calé au fond la doctrine des manuels
macron sur le dosage de liberté de
responsabilité par et puis
d'accompagnement par la puissance
publique il a toujours voulu incarner
les deux une sorte d'équilibré en même
temps le fameux en même temps mais on
voit que la les temps les temps sont
très dur pour les français le pouvoir
d'achat au delà la question du pouvoir
d'achat de combien on peut acheter quand
on fait ses courses il ya tout un tas
d'autres
préoccupations qui sont là à travers la
question du pouvoir d'achat c'est aussi
évidemment la question de l'échelle des
revenus qui est posée et c'est sacré le
coeur du débat entre ceux qui disent des
mesures tout de suite et puis ceux qui
dénoncent dans ces mesures un pansement
sur une jambe de bois et que parle
davantage peut-être de l'échelle des
rémunérations qu'est ce que veut dire
bien rémunérer le travail dans un pays
riche et développé comme le nôtre donc
ça ne sont pas que des mesures
techniques on revient à ce que ce que
vous nous décrivez la semaine dernière
guillaume il a manqué des députés
renaissance dans l'hémicycle des députés
horizons aussi est-ce que des consignes
ont été données pour resserrer les rangs
cette fois sur la majorité est ce que
c'est un texte un texte pardon qui
stresse l'exécutif en tout cas qui le
mobilise ils ont clairement appelé à
battre le rappel des troupes puisque
avant même la semaine dernière
appelez-vous emmanuel macron quand il
avait reçu les parlementaires il avait
dit il faut que la majorité soit
cohérente qu'elle soit solide et qu'elle
soit là pour voter les textes premier
coup c'était loupé très clairement ce
qui se dit aussi dans la majorité c'est
que c'est vrai que c'est compliqué
d'incarner cette nouvelle méthode quand
dd vu la majorité dit à la fois par la
voix d'emmanuel macron oui je veux
entendre les oppositions et que dès le
début les ministres disent non quasiment
à toutes les propositions de
l'opposition on peut juger comme on le
souhaite les propositions par exemple de
la nuque du smic à 1500 euros de le
remonter aussi deux des républicains de
limiter le coût du plein d'essence qui
aurai je crois un coût de 30 milliards
d'euros mais c'est des propositions qui
sont mises sur la table dès le début la
majorité dit niet pour la marge de
négociation c'est un peu compliqué et
par ailleurs le deuxième écueil est la
deuxième difficulté qui apparaît
clairement pour le gouvernement et pour
la majorité c'est qu'il lui faut tout à
la fois apparaître protecteur sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français ça veut
dire débloquer des fonds et en même
temps si j'ose dire on voit que le
président de la république et le
ministre de l'économie siffler quand
même la fin de la récré budgétaire en
dix ans le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
terminé c'était plus facile de protéger
les français pendant la crise si j'ose
dire quand les milliards coulé à flots
pour de bonnes raisons aujourd'hui oui
ce qui est compliqué c'est dire on va
vous protéger mais en même temps faut
serrer les cordons la voir faire
attention à chaque et eric de la caisse
qui se joue au fond dans ce projet de
risque sont des réponses conjoncturelles
ou structurelles aux problèmes
quotidiens des français aujourd'hui tel
que le projet de loi et imaginez on est
plutôt sur des réponses conjoncturelles
et c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
envie de dire que les rifains le piège
il est potentiellement pour les deux
pour la majorité et les oppositions pour
la majorité parce qu'effectivement se
joue là une potentielle nouvelle méthode
un premier test de mise en commun de
quelque chose pour répondre à une
attente des français un piège pour les
oppositions parce que s'ils vont vers
une opposition systématique on va être
amené à voir des débats incessants à
faire finalement en sorte que les aides
qui sont promises aux français ne vont
pas arriver et d'ailleurs le rn l'a très
bien compris un qui a quasiment donné
des des signes comme quoi ils voteraient
un texte pour aller dans l'intérêt des
français donc le piège en fait il est
pour les deux et moi j'ai presque envie
de dire que c'est un vin un texte de loi
qui est un des plus faciles finalement y
compris pour la majorité pourquoi un des
plus faciles parce qu'il s'agit de
distribuer des chèques imaginez les
twitter désormais falloir qu'on fasse
autant oui alors oui l'équilibré la
difficulté elle est potentiellement
trouver le bon équilibre mais il s'agit
de distribuer des chèques et pas de
réformer
le monde imaginez quand il va falloir
commencer à travailler sur les réformes
de fond ou des visions de la société
vont s'affronter réagir ci fut facile de
distribuer des chèques plutôt que de se
poser la question de savoir comment on
doit prendre en compte la valeur travail
dans une réforme de l'assurance chômage
par exemple où est-ce qu'on m'ait appelé
exactement donc on est sûr finalement à
un exercice compliqué sur lequel il ya
effectivement un piège de savoir se
mettre d'accord mais qui est
relativement facile par rapport à ce qui
nous attend dans les prochaines années
l'opposition est elle vraiment intérêt à
bloquer le texte c'est le rappeler
comment les français ne le
comprendraient twt à ya un risque
effectivement d'apparaître comme celui
qui bloque et qui empêche quand même des
mesures en faveur des français alors
pour le moment dans les enquêtes les
gens nous disent les français nous
disaient plutôt sais c'est une bonne
chose qui est cette opposition renforcée
ça va être revitalisé le débat ça va
renforcer le parlement donc il y avait
un a priori un peu positif en se disant
ben voilà toutes les propositions vont
être mises sur la table si on n'arrive
vraiment à des blocages ou des débats
très techniques dans lesquelles les
français se reconnaissent pas ou des
mesures qui leur parlent pas forcément
là oui il ya un risque finalement que ça
se retourne contre les oppositions et
qu'elle donne le sentiment de pas
vraiment offrir d'alternative crédible
et d'être finalement dans l'opposition
le rejet systématique et ça je pense
qu'en termes d'image pour elle c'est pas
forcément positif et je rebondis sur ce
que vous me disiez effectivement le
rassemblement national a adopté une
posture différente qui à mon avis dans
l'opinion peut porter ses fruits parce
que effectivement ils apparaissent comme
les pragmatiques qui disent la pouvoir
d'achat préoccupation numéro un des
français on sait que c'est important là
on va pas faire le blocage des eaux et
même si c'est pas un texte
je souhaite que le texte pouvoir d'achat
soit votre soit l'hôte d'un point de vue
opinion ça peut fonctionner alors depuis
quelques semaines le pouvoir exécutif
n'est plus que le mot compromis à la
bouche on l'a entendu martelé notamment
dans la déclaration de politique
générale dz bank est-ce que des
compromis sont trouvables sur ce projet
de loi on va essayer de faire le point
en égrainant quelques propositions de
l'opposition justement avec tam traduit
bonsoir ta main bonsoir monsieur bonsoir
à tous alors les oppositions déjà fait
entendre beaucoup propositions sur le
pouvoir d'achat qu'est ce qui est
négociable et puis qu'est-ce qui ne
l'est pas écoutez on va commencer par le
plus simple le les propositions de la
nuque delà de l'union de la gauche il ya
le smic à 1500 euros net il y à
l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation le blocage des prix sur les
produits de première nécessité encore la
désindexation des loyers au total il ya
eu une vingtaine de mesures 1 que
l'union de la gauche a détaillé la
semaine dernière à travers une
proposition de loi le financement repose
réduit sur une taxation des supers
profits des grands groupes comme total
énergie comme angie ou encore comme les
sociétés d'autoroutes à pourquoi je
disais que c'était simple bas parce que
surtout ça c'est pas compliqué c'est
tout simplement niet pour le
gouvernement aucune négociation possible
et du coup on sent aussi que la ni bhl
se poser frontalement aux mesures au
projet de loi présenté par le
gouvernement on en parlait tous de tout
à l'heure du côté du rassemblement
national qu'est ce que le parti de
marine le pen propose contre alain
renard retenu deux mesures principales 1
d'abord la baisse de la tva de 20% à 5 5
sur le carburant le gaz l'électricité le
fuel un bref l'énergie et puis aussi
cette histoire de tva à zéro pour cent
sur un panier de 100 produits de
première nécessité des mesures que le
rassemblement national veut financer là
encore par une taxation sur les super
profits on retrouve wassila d'elle du
rassemblement national du rassemblement
national avec la lutte contre
l'immigration clandestine la fraude
sociale la baisse de la contribution de
la france à l'union européenne mais vous
avez vous l'avez dit bien que ces
mesures le gouvernement ne compte pas
les reprendre le rn a déjà annoncé que
malgré ça il pourrait peut-être voter le
texte on va écouter jordan bardel à la
semaine dernière chez nos confrères de
france info
est ce que ça veut dire que si j'avais
tout vos amendements ne sont pas repris
vous pourriez quand même voter le texte
parce que après tout c'est mieux que
rien oui parce que je pense qu'il y à
une urgence aujourd'hui dans le pays et
que
même si le texte est un parfait il
apportera quand même même partiellement
même à la marge des solutions à
plusieurs familles françaises on
comprend au niveau politique un
l'objectif du rnc semaine dans une
opposition moins frontale que la nuque
apparaître comme un parti de
gouvernement reste que ce sont là
simplement des déclarations et qu'il est
difficile de prévoir ce que le rl va
faire dans les détails point par point
donc si c'est pas du ps si c'est pas de
rnc du côté de chez l'air qu'il faut
regarder voir ses deux chaussures
négociable avait bien content et mathieu
le gouvernement là a lâché un petit peu
de l'instinct pour obtenir l'adhésion de
la soixantaine de voix et leers et voici
précieuse on en a eu la démonstration à
la semaine dernière l'exécutif a donc
fait un petit pas sur les heures
supplémentaires défiscalisées
le gouvernement a concédé une petite
augmentation du plafond de 5000 à 7500
euros alors que la droite demande est
elle une exonération totale du coup on a
entendu un certain nombre de députés
aient l'air considéré que ce ne sont là
que des miettes en plus de ça il faut
dire que le gouvernement n'a rien lâché
sur le carburant et c'était là l'une des
mesures phares pour les députés aient
l'air à l'assemblée réclame et de fixer
le prix du litre de carburant à 1 euro
50 en baissant les taxes une mesure dont
la droite estime le coût à 15 20
milliards d'euros c'est plutôt 50
milliards 1 selon le gouvernement selon
gabriel attal le nouveau ministre des
comptes publics qui la semaine dernière
a eu des échanges houleux avec les
députés aient l'air on a notamment
retenu une phrase de la première séance
de questions au gouvernement écoute et
vous nous avez accusé de vouloir cramer
la caisse mais vous voulez faire sauter
la banque et c'est les français qui
payerait avec des impôts ce que vous
promettez
voilà une phrase qui a mis le feu aux
poudres qui explique en partie les votes
des 40 lr contre l'article 2 du projet
de loi sanitaire c'était la forme qui
n'a pas beaucoup plu noter que tout à
l'heure bruno le maire a confirmé qu'un
compromis est possible mais pas à coup
de milliards bref dans une négociation
tout compte le fond la forme il suffit
pas dire qu'on est prêt au compromis il
faut apprendre à mettre de l'eau dans
son vin et des effets misme dans son
expression il ya encore un peu de boulot
devant guillaume daret clr qui va faire
monter les enchères
c'est ce qu'on a vu la semaine dernière
c'est effectivement 60 voix qu'ils sont
absolument déterminante mais après les
républicains eux mêmes sont divisés
entre eux sur cette ligne là ce qu'on
sait c'est qu'il ya des appels
permanents qui sont passés en
particulier par les ministres de droite
que soit bruno le maire est évidemment
charge de l'économie et des finances et
y compris de gérald darmanin qui a gardé
des connexions
quelqu'un du gouvernement un ministre du
gouvernement actuel me disait il ya
quelques semaines quand je lui demandais
s'ils étaient missionnés par emmanuel
macron pour aller chercher des voix à
droite me disais non mais ça ne les
empêche pas de le faire
bruno cautrès refusé comme le demandent
a l'air de baisser les taxes sur
l'essence ou ou refuser comme le demande
la nuque ps d'augmenter le smic c'est
seulement une question de coût financier
où il ya aussi une question de coût
politique faire un trop gros cadeau à
l'opposition c'est une question de coût
politique emmanuel macron est fragilisée
depuis les élections législatives n'a
pas de majorité absolue on voit bien que
ça entrave quand même son sens sa
capacité à tout de suite mettre en
oeuvre le projet sur lequel il a été il
a été élu et donc évidemment rien ne
serait pire aux yeux de son électorat
que de voir un emmanuel macron une
elisabeth baume qui tous lui dirai aux
oppositions en fait c'est vous qui avez
raison et donc on voit qu'il ya une
bataille d'interprétation ce qui s'est
très rapidement mises en place sur ce
que veut dire collaborer qu'est ce que
ça veut dire exactement
discuter faire preuve de compromis le
chef de l'état très vite marquer les
limites de l'exercice en disant
compromis à l'intérieur du périmètre de
mon projet présidentiel je suis prêt à
faire des concessions je suis prêt à
écouter je suis père remettre sur la
table et remettre sur le métier certains
points mais le périmètre c'est le projet
sur lequel j'ai été élu et il ne cesse
de rappeler qu'il a été élu président la
république avant les élections
législatives
du côté des oppositions ondimba depuis
les législatives tout à tout a changé
les français ont envoyé un message ils
ont élu emmanuel macron parce qu'ils ne
voulaient pas de marine le pen au fond
ne voulait pas des politiques emmanuel
macron et le cadre du projet
présidentiel des mamelles macron at il
rappelé ce sont aussi des contraintes de
finances publiques là on parle d'une
addition à au moins 20 milliards d'euros
bruno le maire de nice de l'économie
déjà tiré la sonnette d'alarmé il a
parlé des dykes la cote d alerte avait
été déplacé la semaine dernière il a
parlé de folie financière de quelques
propositions de l'opposition il a raison
eric delannoy je trouve qu'en ce moment
tous les partis politiques jouent un
climat anxiogène et entretiennent un
climat anxiogène que ce soit la nuit
baisse en prétendant que j'ai entendu
tout à l'heure on est en une inflation
absolument vertigineuse on est à 5 8%
peut-être peut-être à 7 ont fin d'année
faut se rappeler qu'il ya 20 ans en 2015
15 % comparée à nos voisins européens
c'est ils ont un faible score entre 2 et
4 po et quatre points de moins donc il
ya des mots comme ça qui sont pris on
parle de bruno le maire vous venez lui
rappeler bref un climat anxiogène qui a
entretenu par tout le monde moi je
voudrais rappeler quand même que si le
projet du gouvernement est pris en
l'état l'insee estime que la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat estimée en année pleine
serait de 1 % est-ce qu'on a des gens
qui vont pas pouvoir manger parce que
baisse du pouvoir d'achat est de 1% je
voudrais rappeler une étude de l'insee
qui est sorti il ya très peu de temps
qui fait la démonstration d'une enquête
sur les privations des individus et
qu'une enquête sur sur plusieurs années
tous les indicateurs se sont améliorées
jusqu'en 2021 parce qu'effectivement le
pouvoir d'achat s'est améliorée jusqu'en
2021 avant effectivement l'inflation qui
augmente
le nombre de français conduits là les
grandes les regarde autant il ya six ans
il ya six pour cent des gens qui déclare
c'était à ct 9% en 2014 il ya 6 % des
gens qui déclarent plus de ne pas
pouvoir manger de la viande du poisson
tous les 2 jours 6 % des français donc
oui à des difficultés oui il faut
traiter les difficultés mais il faut
arrêter de mettre en place un climat
anxiogène y compris sur les
problématiques de la dette parce que si
effectivement bruno le maire a raison de
rappeler il faut faire en sorte
d'arrêter le quoi qu'il en coûte on est
sur une dette qui aujourd'hui soutenable
avec la hausse des taux d'intérêts elle
risque de ne plus le devenir mais
horizon 2 3 4 ont donc on a encore des
marges de manoeuvre malheureusement ses
marges de manoeuvre ont fait pour
distribuer des chèques plutôt que pour
mettre en place des réformes
structurelles et c'est bien là qu'est le
problème mais avec une opposition telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui on n'a pas le
choix que d'aller à l'encontre d'un
climat anxiogène qui est parfaitement
entretenus aujourd'hui regardez les
réservations des vacances regard des
autres regardez ce qui se passe sur les
plages on n'est pas dans un pays du
tiers-monde comme essayer de le rappeler
un membre du r n ya pas si longtemps que
ça dernier point très important a cité
c'est que on n'entend plus parler des
problématiques d'écologie en gros on
veut limiter le prix de l'essence mais
l'état en a parlé le jeu attention oui
mais vous rendez compte quand même qu'en
limitant prix de l'essence à 1 50
alors que le pouvoir d'achat augmenter
quand ils terrain 90 ça n'a aucun sens
ni écologique ni financier le signal
prix c'est quand même un des rares
signal qui reste pour limiter les
déplacements des français avait avec la
conservation des sens alors pour trouver
de l'argent il ya une idée qui refleurit
c'est taxer les super profits des supers
profiteurs
ça va être très populaire c'est légitime
ou c'est de la démagogie je me
prononcerai pas sur le front mais
effectivement commencé ce sont des
mesures qui sont qui sont très
populaires quand on leur dit faut taxer
les plus riches comme chacun estime
qu'il ne fait pas partie des plus riches
c'est effectivement des mesures qui et
voilà qu'ils sont qui sont très
populaires donc voilà ça va pas suffire
mais je rebondissais quand même sur ce
que vous disiez parce que oui c'est vrai
il ya des indicateurs économiques mais
dans le ressenti des français ce parce
qu'ils nous disent en fait ils ont le
sentiment pour beaucoup que leur pouvoir
d'achat se dégrade peut-être qu'ils
peuvent manger tous les jours bien sûr
mais il ya certains biens auxquels ils
ont le sentiment de ne plus avoir accès
ou ils ont le sentiment d'être un peu
déclassé et ça ça entretient quand même
un climat où ils ont sentiment
finalement ça ne va pas que leur vie va
moins bien et alors peut-être que s'est
entretenue par un climat anxiogène mais
ils du coup quand il se projette dans
l'avenir c'est c'est assez de manière
assez catastrophique ils ont
l'impression que leurs enfants vont
vivre moins bien qu'eux ils appréhendent
énormément l'hiver et les prochains mois
à venir en se demandant s'ils vont
pouvoir faire face à leurs factures donc
même si derrière c'est pas forcément des
chiffres qui s'y colle aux jurés
classement et plus joueur et ne voulait
ma foi de la réalité
je vous tue dans l'interception à la
came convenir vendant toutes les
enquêtes d'opinion
le sentiment à la fois d'un
ascenseur social qui est bloqué le
sentiment d'une société française qui ne
tient pas sa promesse d'égalité le
sentiment que la méritocratie qui est
tellement important dans notre discours
politique au fond c'est un discours mais
qu'on ne le voit jamais vraiment bien
dans la dans la réalité et je pense
qu'effectivement en termes de perception
il ya cette perception qui aimait
pourquoi je vis dans un pays riche et
j'ai encore des difficultés pour boucler
la fin du mois alors je pense que tant
que les politiques n'arrivent pas à
rentrer dans cette équation à trouver
des solutions
au fond là on voit que quand on pose les
questions comme ça on retourne vers les
grands mécanismes d'injustices et
d'inégalités sociales mais bruno si
c'est tout ça qui se joue dans ce projet
doit pouvoir d'achat risque d'y avoir
jamais assez basses et ça on disait tout
à l'heure il n'y a jamais assez j'en
disais tout à l'heure il ya une vraie je
pense qu'une vraie différence entre d'un
côté ceux qui perçoivent la société
française comme en difficulté qui ne va
pas bien mais il suffirait de réparer là
où ça ne va pas bien et ceux qui ne
veulent pas réparer la société française
mais que la transformer voire sur des
projets de transformation assez radicale
de véritable changement de paradigme
important et donc on voit qu'autour de
sang on retrouve les vieux débat
politique
ce qu'il faut réformer la société ce
qu'il faut révolutionner la société
c'est aussi tout ça ce sont de vieux
vieux débat politique pour ce qui est de
la super taxe sur les super-profits
voiture là aussi c'est niet la part des
manuels macouin du gouvernement attend
pourtant lui-même dénoncé le chef
derrière celui mort mais le chef de
l'état en lui opposait plusieurs
reprises la question il a toujours dit
non bruno le maire aussi a dit non tout
en laissant planer une forme de menace
ou salées en disant on fera le point à
la fin de l'année sur ces entreprises
qui ont super profiter et qui ont fait
des super profits justement sur cette
inflation mais pour l'instant on préfère
inciter les entreprises c'est vrai qu'à
chaque prise de parole au ministre de
l'économie dit on incite les entreprises
qui le peuvent a elle aussi participé
cet effort et à augmenter les salaires
mais pas d'obligation formellement et
pas de taxe sur les super profits alors
parlé de compromis tout à l'heure de la
part du gouvernement mais est ce que les
opposer vraiment prête elle aussi à
faire des compromis et je pense qu'elles
n'ont pas envie parce que parce que
manifestement et enfin elles ont elles
vont fortement envie de déstabiliser le
gouvernement on sent bien que la nuque
baisse à une stratégie de conflictuelle
isation permanente enfin ce qui n'est
pas forcément le cas d'ailleurs de l'air
je pense que il ya un vrai risque de
droitisation de la politique d' emmanuel
macron parce qu'il a bien compris qu'il
est plus facile d'aller capter une
partie des 60 députés l air que
d'essayer d'aller chercher quelques
députés socialistes et quelques députés
écologistes alors qu'il n'arrivera
jamais à faire de compromis me
semble-t-il avec les stars gauche les
socialistes qui n'avaient pas voté
contre le projet et avec 20 il n'a pas
de majorité absolue avec 40 de l air il
arrive à avoir une majorité absolue donc
le riz c'est une droitisation de la
politique ce qui explique d'ailleurs que
sur le certainement qui explique qu'il
ne souhaite pas une surtaxe des
surprofits qui est typiquement un
marqueur de droite alors qu'en espagne
on voit bien que ça a été mis en place
il ya pas si longtemps que ça et que ça
serait pas complètement illogique en
fait alors vous parlez des insoumis eric
des insoumis qui n'ont pas attendu le
paquet pouvoir d'achat pour donner de la
voix à l'image de mathilde panneaux la
députée du val-de-marne fait beaucoup
parler d'elle depuis qu'elle a été élue
à la tête du groupe 1 soumis à
l'assemblée nationale a de nouveau
déclenché la polémique ce week end avec
ce tweet que vous voyez à l'écran qui
explique en gros il ya 80 ans les
collaborationnistes du régime de vichy
est organisée la rafle du vel d'hiv ne
pas oublier ces crimes aujourd'hui plus
que jamais avec un président de la
république qui rend honneur à pétain et
89 députés et rennes alors fait feu
déclenché beaucoup beaucoup de réactions
y compris à gauche pour condamner ces
propos bien écouter celle du sénateur
socialiste patrick kanner c'était
persiste et signe moi je le regrette je
le regrette parce que finalement elle
reconnaît qu'il y à une émotion lisez
peut-être à une incompréhension sept cas
c'est ce qu'elle a fait en 2 200 tweets
je pense qu'il aurait été beaucoup plus
raisonnable en responsabilité en
crédibilité y compris pour la présidente
du plus grand groupe à l'assemblée
nationale à gauche et bien tout
simplement de retirer sans suite pour ne
pas choquer encore plus ceux qui ont été
particulièrement voilà affectée par de
tels de tels propos manifestement elle a
voulu attaquer le président maquereau en
profitant en instrumentalisant ce que
j'ai expliqué mon propre 8 la rafle du
vel d'hiv c'est tellement dommage
comment vous qualifier ce tweet monoko
presse c'est un dérapage on voit je me
prononcerai pas sur le fond parce qu'on
voit que le débat est déjà assez
passionnel s'enflammer mais bonjour
juste part en diamant du fonds pour les
téléspectateurs qui auraient manqué un
épisode ça fait référence à des propos
tenus par un binôme macron en 2018 qui
saluait le maréchal pétain grands
soldats de 14-18 tout en disant que par
la suite on pouvait avoir été un grand
soldat en 14-18 et avoir eu une
politique beaucoup plus funestes ensuite
évidemment il faisait allusion là au
régime de vichy de l'ordre soient
parfois qu'on retrouve des débats là
aussi qui sont des débats politiques
dans lequel on revient très
régulièrement la vie politique française
un rapport à la fois viscérale
fondamentale passionnel difficile à
toute une partie de son passé et
notamment tout ce qui concerne cette
période
le président jacques chirac avait marqué
à son époque en reconnaissant la
responsabilité de l'état français dans
la déportation dans la rafle notamment
et on voit que ça n'a pas suffi pour
calmer le débat sur ces questions sur
ces questions en france il faut dire que
notre pays a vécu une expérience que
aucun autre pays européen n'a vécu en
tout cas de l'europe on va dire
continentale de l'europe
dans laquelle nous vivons l'europe
occidentale qui est une occupation par
une force
ennemi qui a occupé notre pays ça a
laissé des traces en profondeur c'est
une perte dramatique de notre histoire
et donc on voit un rapport qui est
toujours un rapport très compliqué à
cette question mais pour arrière eut
utilisé la commémoration je pensais
vivre ce n'est pas une faute politique
par ailleurs je pense que on voit que
sur ces questions là la très grande
sensibilité d'avoir évoqué cette
question effectivement dans ce jour-là
ou en tout cas quelques heures avant
cette commémoration est sans doute il ya
là une maladresse qui est une maladresse
relativement importante l'ats la cheffe
du groupe des insoumis s'est expliqué en
disant qu'elle n'avait fait que dire des
choses objectives rappelant que chef de
l'état effectivement avait dit qu'il y
avait eu un premier pétain qui était
celui de 14-18 et un deuxième pétain
celui d'allah salla même dit qu'elle
était une lanceuse d'aller voilà elle
était une en salade qui n'a fait que
rappeler des choses qui sont des
éléments factuels on voit bien qu'il n'y
avait pas que du factuel dans ce tweet
qu'il y avait évidemment l'idée de
mettre en difficulté emmanuel macron est
encore une fois en début de législature
de porter le faire et de dire tout de
suite nous sommes des insoumis et nous
allons contester emmanuel macron dans
tout
sur cette question on voit d'ailleurs
apparaître des éléments de
différenciation au sein de la nuque
comme on l'a vu avec
comme on l'a vu
sans aucun doute que cette nouvelle
coalition est encore une construction un
peu fragile et j'imagine que si des
événements de cette nature était amené à
se répliquer au cours des six mois ou
dès maintenant qui arrive ça va sans
aucun doute mettre en difficulté en tout
cas des paroles verbales le verbe des
propos forts j'allais dire un peu
provocateur à
incarner l'alternance numéro 1 emmanuel
mâcon quand vous échanger avec eux ils
vous disent maintenant on est à
l'assemblée l'objectif c'est de bien
montrer que l'alternance à emmanuel
m'apprend dans cinq ans c'est
certainement pas les républicains c'est
pas le rassemblement national qui vaudra
peut-être certains textes ou
s'abstiendra et alternance c'est la
france insoumise c'est la nuque c'est
nous et quelque part derrière les propos
de matt hill panneaux on voit que ça
sert presque emmanuel macron dans ce
qu'il décrit politiquement et sa volonté
effectivement de de scinder cette
alliance de gauche il qu'on le voit
depuis les élections législatives ou
clairement il parle jamais de la nuque
il parle des socialistes de construire
éventuellement une majorité parfois avec
des socialistes des communistes et des
écologistes qui seraient finalement les
partenaires
tolérable au sein de manu p puis à l'est
les partenaires infréquentable ou
intolérable au sein de la nuque qui sont
les insomnies et j'allais dire que
paradoxalement des propos comme ceux
tenus par mathilde panneaux servent le
chef de l'état est ce que je crois qui
est intéressant aussi dans ce qu'on a vu
dire c'est que paradoxalement la hausse
y ait des choses étonnantes ou en tout
cas qui sont à souligner c'est que dans
le même temps je pas si vous avez vu
marine le pen qui est parfois accusé
évidemment par ses opposants d'être là
successeur d'un parti où il y avait des
participants au régime de vichy des
pétainistes a publié un tweet hier pour
expliquer je vais vous le lire qu'il
fallait évidemment rendre hommage à tous
ces français qui était tombé n'oublions
jamais l'horreur du vel d'hiv 13000
juifs 82 ans après le combat contre la
haine antisémite ne doit jamais faiblir
elle évidemment elle fait attention à
faire à 100 foot alors qu'elle était
entrée à l'assemblée à nouveau on va
parler d'une autre petite phrase qui
continue de faire parler qui a été
prononcée celle-ci par la nouvelle mise
collectivités locales madame cayeux sur
notre antenne la semaine dernière alors
c'était à propos de ce qu'elle disait du
mariage pour tous il ya dix ans j'ai le
lire ici c'est qu'elle considérait que
c'était une ouverture de droits
irrespectueuse de la nature et insensé
interrogé par public sénat d'abord
expliqué qu'elle maintenait ses propos
et puisqu'elle comptait beaucoup d'amis
parmi ces gens là at elle dit ce sont
des guillemets que jamais devant le
tollé elle a ensuite présenté ses
excuses à la fait machine arrière mais
on a l'impression que rien n'y fait ce
week end encore une pétition rassemblant
des élus les intellectuels des
scientifiques des médecins parue dans le
jdd pour condamner ces propos homophobes
on peut avoir été contre le mariage pour
tous et faire partie de ce gouvernement
arrive à nous alors c'est une question
intéressante dans la temporalité j'ai
l'impression que oui j'aurais envie de
dire je n'aurais pas envie de répondre à
cette émotion oui si on se dit que il ya
dix ans cette dame a maturé a changé
d'avis on a le droit de changer des vies
dans une carrière je rappelle que la
début de carrière de lionel jospin et
trotskistes donc on peut pas dire que
c'est quand même l'archétype de trotski
ce qu'on avait eue en communion entre
vétérans plus exactement donc on a le
droit de changer d'avis ce qui pose
problème et qui fait que la polémique ne
s'éteint pas c'est qu'on change pas
d'avis à une semaine d'intervalle c'est
dire qu'en gros après dix ans
d'intervalle elle remet à l'ordre du
jour sur votre plateau un imaginaire ses
terres que quand elle déclare ces gens
là elle révèle son imaginaire en fait
elle ne fait pas une bourde elle révèle
son imaginaire qui prouve conception de
en fait elle n'a pas changé en dix ans
et c'est pas ensuite en s'excusant parce
qu'elle s'aperçoit qu'elle fait une
énorme bêtise parce qu un imaginaire
quand il est pas terrible bah on
s'aperçoit qu'il n'est pas terrible et
ben forcément là elle fait tout ce qu'il
faut pour rétropédaler et donc moi ce
que je la réponse que j'ai envie de
faire jouir d'un droit change d'avis en
une semaine ça ressemble alger c'est de
sauver mon poste et à ce titre là pardon
je pense qu'on n'a pas besoin de
personnes qui sont qui ont cet
imaginaire là dans le gouvernement
français alors que pour le coup il m'a
dit emmanuel macron n'a jamais eu aucune
ambiguïté sur le sujet sur cette
thématique là et ça lui rappelait
l'homophobie sa baisse dans l'opinion on
a l'impression que l'homosexualité
sondage après sondage est de plus en
plus d'accepter oui il ya quand même une
acceptation un peu plus forte de la
c'est paradoxal ya globalement une
acceptation un peu plus forte notamment
de l'adoption du mariage entre
homosexuels mais en même temps on a vu
quand même en 2012 ça au moment de la
loi à se réactiver des oppositions assez
fort dans certains segments de l'opinion
qui restent très minoritaires mais qui
ont trouvé finalement une forme d'écho à
ce moment là et c'est vrai que
finalement cette polémique vient raviver
cette ce segment là de la population
qu'on entendait un peu moins ces
derniers temps cailleux est une ancienne
enfin elle vient des rangs de l est
cette dernière partie de ce débat sur
les républicains qui veut devenir patron
des vacances par an alors que christian
jacob a quitté la tête du parti avant
les vacances avec les militants sont
appelés à trancher désigner leur futur
chef ça c'est cet automne enfin
guillaume n y en a qu à jeter l'épongé
hier soir dans un très long post les
réseaux sociaux c'est laurent wauquiez
pourquoi cette décision parce qu'il est
convaincu qu après trois défaites
successives la droite doit absolument et
totalement se refonder du sol au plafond
que ce soit sur la forme ou sur le fond
et y pense que ça passe pas par la
présidence du parti déjà parce qu'il
veut conserver sa liberté de parole
qu'on lui connaît parce qu'ensuite il
pense qu'en termes de notoriété
il a absolument rien à y gagner et parce
qu'ensuite il veut construire quelque
chose qui irait au delà même des
républicains alors 2027 mathieu c'est
encore très loin et pourtant ils
commencent dès aujourd'hui puisque dès
la rentrée il va multiplier laurent
wauquiez les déplacements sur le terrain
il fera plus de médias aussi on l'a un
peu moins vu rappelez vous ces derniers
mois il s'est consacré à sa région ce
sera moins le cas à partir de septembre
pour peser des petits cailloux et est
montrée justement quelle est cette
nouvelle identité politique l'a façonnée
est ce que je peux vous dire ce que me
disait son entourage c'est qu'aussi va
s'intéresser très près ce qui s'est fait
dans les autres pays est un pays en
particulier le royaume uni ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir comment les
conservateurs ont réussi à refonder le
courant de pensée conservateur des
tories après tony blair blair qui lui
même avait l'image de quelqu'un qui
avait réussi un petit peu à trianguler
au delà des forces politiques
traditionnelles l'un de ses conseillers
il me disait regarde effectivement que
ce soit boris johnson david cameron même
si ça même mal fait ça s'est mal finie
je vous le concède ils ont réussi à
totalement parlera tout à l'heure où lui
verser la base électorale traditionnelle
des conservateurs
c'est ce qui leur a permis d'être réélu
il va notamment se pencher là dessus un
peu de benchmarking comme on dit et la
décision de laurent wauquiez s'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle pour l'air
ah ça c'est certain parce que les
républicains se retrouve aujourd'hui
mathieu sans leader pas beaucoup de
militants et sans ligne politique ce
n'est pas faire injure quand même à
bruno retailleau qui est sénateur
d'ailleurs à aurélien pradié ou eric
ciotti qui peuvent peut-être prétendre à
prendre la présidence du parti de dire
que c'est pas du même niveau que laurent
wauquiez et pour les républicains ça va
être compliqué face à jean luc mélenchon
face à marine le pen face à emmanuel
macron ne pas avoir quelqu'un qui
incarne fortement la ligne politique des
républicains pour ce qui est des
militants ils sont à peu près cent
trente mille cent cinquante mille mais
la plupart sont venus rappeler ou pour
le vote du congrès pour choisir deux
sera candidat a pu rentrer direct et
creysse à l'élection présidentielle et
puis on en parlait il ya quelques
minutes la ligne politique quelle est la
ligne politique des républicains
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est et d
emmanuel macron sur certaines réformes
ou au contraire une opposition frontale
est extrêmement forte et bien qu à deux
défis - qui marquent particulièrement et
qui vont être compliqués à résoudre pour
les républicains c'est que sur le fond
il va pas falloir que leurs nouveaux
logiciels soient fondées seulement et
uniquement sur l'anti macro nisme parce
que par définition dans cinq ans
emmanuel macron ne pourra pas être
candidat à sa succession et puis il
faudra surtout pas que les républicains
croient que dans cinq ans le pouvoir va
leur revenir avec matti valence et
mécanique grâce à balancier parce
qu'aujourd'hui vous fait confiance est
là dessus quand on regarde les études
d'opinion ceux qui incarnent le mieux
l'alternance possible emmanuel macron
c'est le rassemblement national et la
france a soumises rapidement pour faire
un boulot il ya un profil idéal pour
l'élève est certain c'est qu'il faut une
personnalité qui progressivement montre
qui est un projet qui s'affirme et la
difficulté pour les républicains c'est
que ce projet il faut pas que ça
revienne à ce que les républicains
faisait déjà il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans
il ya vingt ans en disant on dépense
trop il faut serrer la vis il faut que
l'état s'occupe moins de choses ça
équivaut d'émigrés qui voit là parce que
là on vous dira mais où est la nouveauté
c'est ce qu'ils racontent depuis 15 ans
20 ans qui ne leur a pas réussi donc un
vrai difficulté pour eux c'est de
trouver effectivement quelqu'un qui a à
la fois l'équation personnelle le
charisme le leadership mais qui en même
temps est susceptible de dire autre
chose que ce qu'on entend depuis quinze
ou vingt ans ils sont longtemps d'avoir
tiré les leçons de la défaite de nicolas
sarkozy et celle de françois et de celle
de valérie ya un favori dans les
sondages non et quand on regarde nous on
a une cote d'affluence de qui on
aimerait qu'ils aient qui joue un rôle à
l'avenir et ben c'est edouard philippe
qui reprend un peu du galon auprès des
sympathisants et l'air
avec vous et eric c'est une affaire
surtout de casting ou de lignes comme
les et guillaume à votre avis et dorures
et deux parce que il ya une grande
partie du casting dlr qui
malheureusement pardon d'expression
s'est cramé avec l'élection
présidentielle on voit bien qu'il ya un
écartement qui est impossible à
maintenir entre un eric ciotti est rien
et un david lisnard mois david lisnard
fait partie des gens dont on n'a pas
entendu parler qui restaient très
discrets qui a potentiellement une ligne
a affirmé la ligne que vous affirmez
david lisnard et qui pourrait
potentiellement porteuses c'est enfin de
réussir à réenchanter la politique
objectivement ce que n'a pas réussi à
faire emmanuel macron merci à tous
[Musique]